hard work is your ticket in it doesn't
guarantee your success but without it
you don't stand a chance I remember
asking my dad - I want a new basketball
shoes because I was a basketball junkie
back then he's like well your shoes work
if you want a new pair of tennis shoes
you have to go out there and get a job
I'd say the one thing my father gave me
which was really key was that work ethic
that ability to get myself up in the
morning no matter how tired I was ah to
push myself through those pain barriers
being sent out to work at ten we started
work out five o'clock in the morning
through the mill ground being dropped
off at 8:45 at school in the milkman you
know there at work ethic so that
combination of those two work ethic and
great insecurity was what got me to
where I went to
[Music]
I realized that I have to be very
hardworking because I don't have kind of
the ease of talent and I come from that
and I think it is you know a lot of ways
that served me very well in that I am is
kind of hard-working as I've ever been
completely on without confidence and I
have none I don't I don't want any
because I think you turn your back on
the thing and that's when you get gored
is when you think I got this I never
think I got this I think oh man don't
screw this up I'm trying to be fully
engaged
[Music]
there's nothing in life that you can't
you can't put enough work in every
single day and not get better at you
know what I mean like if you want to be
good at something you know I mean like
you can't just like not like do it every
day and not get better this is
essentially what musics the same
learning how to play an instrument
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
it's understanding what your skillset is
finding the right place to use those
skills and then going for it but
whatever industry you pick if you
outwork everybody if you try to be a
little smarter than everybody if you try
to be a better salesperson and everybody
if you try to be better prepared than
everybody you've got your best chance
because if you don't do it and somebody
else does the I have the same work like
someone's trying to take it all away
from you you know work now you actually
working like no one's spending 24 hours
working 24 hours to take it all away
from you and that's kind of the way I
look at it job good job
you're still thinking but your ratio
thinking to acting is very different you
know you're at the beginning I was
thinking about it this much yeah you
know in my cognitive brain and then
there was this much just whatever thin
read of talent you have is there and
then you're thinking about the rest and
then over the years I think you know
they always say the reptile brain you
the reptile portion of your brain is
where you you know respiration heartbeat
right that's the stuff that even if
you're knocked unconscious it's still
working
I really believe a lot of my talk show
or comedy instincts are now in my
reptile brain it's 4:45 a.m. it's still
dark outside look at that lights just
went out and I'm getting ready to kill
this am car do you can't even see me but
it's gonna be so good it's bad now get
up at crazy hours so whatever time might
call time is and I tell this to Studios
and directors and our producers whatever
time I call time so my call time is at
7:00 then you back your clock up for
hours and then that's when I get out and
train twice I'll get my cardio in and
breakfast and I'll go hit the weights
[Music]
clanging and banging we call it Jack and
higher but like what time do you go to
bed I mean you might shoot really late
at night I'm averaging on a movie on
average probably about five hours of
sleep I'm excited to be hosting a talk
show on Hollywood Boulevard I've always
dreamed of working three doors down from
a Wetzel's pretzels I used to stay out
of it I don't care I don't want a
harness
I don't need it you know and this is my
business now this is me you know it is
important if my agent that way agent
always says I move I'm his only client
that doesn't recall them back as soon as
he is my business and I expect menu
agent said you only find it calls him
back to say mediately the iris attorney
emails I return phone calls I've worked
really hard to build this and I want to
continue building it and it's my
business my personal business so I don't
understand how people do slack I'm a
workaholic and like being an alcoholic I
just trying to get it up getting my wife
and my sad little telling movie you know
he works closely around the clock
why I keep doing this I don't think I
need the money I don't think I'm greedy
for more fame I'm doing okay I can't do
one foot in two years and you'd be happy
with it but I'm just one happy I don't
know if it's a curse or a blessing I
have this fear that you have very few
days in life and you need to cram it up
with lot of things you need to further
fill it with so many things and add that
you don't have space for life you know
hard work pays I put in a hell of a walk
all throughout this build up in the fire
I think they're more content than
anybody more content and Fox more
content than ESPN more content than the
air BT sport more content and everybody
on the Maglev
my own channels you know man I'm
workhorse from all angles not just in
the gym I'm building this media empire
and myself we pumped out the content I'm
pretty proud of how it went
we consistently daily movies I was
releasing you know from from like a
month ago every single day you know I
mean nobody's doing that that's why I'm
I'm sitting at the top I poured it all
on the line I show up like perform and I
get the results from that it doesn't
sound sexy
it doesn't sound cool work ethic you
know and just it how badly do you want
it and there's been you know many times
in the you know throughout the years of
doing my show where I've thought you
could shoot me in the chest before I
walk out there and I'll still walk out
there and do that show and then I'll
come backstage and die but we're doing
that show every damn person who said I
wouldn't be anything I'm crushing them
every day everybody I had to endure in
any band I was in every day into a
powder yeah thank you and I wish them no
ill I just wish to shine brighter and if
it burns my body to a crisp I'm happy to
go right now I have to be half-dead not
to not go to work but it's kind of the
work ethic that's built into me Friday
night as you got back from the officials
on the workers in the factory or
whatever no matter what was buzzing
around in my head it was off like a
light switch
Monday morning bang back on it again as
if you could flip the switch on again so
I have a bit of discipline in that
respect yeah
the last boss I ever had was my boss at
haagen-dazs I my ice cream shop and to
this day he still comes to my shows and
whenever I see Steve who got me my first
apartment who bootie I was living in my
car he believed in me whenever I see him
I get all weepy that's good to see you
sir
Henry you can call me Steve I can't do
that sir cuz cuz he trusted me with his
money and and I said let me run your
store I know how to do this I can do
this he's like well if you screw up
you're out of here I said I won't
I fired a staff and rehired a bunch of
people can really work and it's it was
out of anger like I'll be back in four
hours to run this $3.75 hour job into
the ground and I'm so she I'm very odd
with people I have replaced loneliness
depression and people good work because
when I'm working I would a lot of people
and there are people I can interact with
because somewhere there is a wall that
I'm not interacting with them socially
I'm interacting them through this common
you know goal that is the work many of
my filmmaking colleagues complained that
after the film is over you don't talk to
us I can't explain to them I don't have
anything else to say I love you I miss
you right I miss you
through the work I was 16 I think when I
started a stamp company and started
going to stamp shows and trade shows and
just working a little bit harder than
other people and and trading up from one
stamp to the next I remember one time I
started with a quarter and bought a
stamp and left with fifty dollars
thinking hey if I could do this I could
do anything and and it's not that
everything worked I failed a lot but I
never ever felt like I I wouldn't be
able to work hard enough to succeed then
I joined Black Flag and I thought I was
a hard working person then you meet the
guys in Black Flag who are so driven
you'd see Greg Ginn work 23 hour days
like Greg you're still on the phone I
know Greg when did you eat I don't know
Greg when the last time you showered do
we have a shower like the guy we were
not going to be stopped and I kind of go
at that intensity
what kind of anything I do nobody in
life gets exactly what they thought they
were going to get but if you work really
hard and you're kind amazing things will
happen hey believe nation thank you guys
so much for watching this video this is
a new style of video that we're looking
at making on a regular basis and I would
love to know what did you think do you
like this style do you like the more
cinematic inspirational tone to it
please please please let me know what
you liked what you would fix or change
what potential topics you want me to
cover next let me know down in the
comments below I really really really
appreciate it and look forward to
hearing your feedback thank you guys so
much for watching I believe in you I
hope we continue to believe in yourself
and whatever you're one where it is
much love I'll see you soon raise your
standard apple at the core its core
value is that we believe that people
with passion can not one drop of my
self-worth depends on your acceptance of
me
I don't ever give up I'd have to be dead
or completely incapacitated hey believe
nation if you want to see my all-time
favorite top ten most a success I have a
very special secret video for you these
are the individual Clips that I have
personally learned the most from and
applied to my life and my business check
the link in description for details